[Musique]
ok mon premier album
auc six sort le 24 septembre
[Musique]
bon cris renouveau j'avais annoncé à la
fin du clip de guépard ceux qui suivent
la chaîne depuis un moment vous l'avez
vu arriver c'est pas nouveau j'ai
toujours fait pas mal de musique sur
cette chaîne youtube
même si ça n'a pas toujours été des
réussites évidemment adolphe il qu'à un
gap et des graphismes toxicomanes été
tué on n'est pas des peaux hâlées on
oubliait fait comme s'il n'y avait
jamais eu ça et d'ailleurs la première
vidéo qui a hyper marché sur ma chaîne
youtube c'était une musique puisque
c'était une parodie de max boublil qui
s'appelait j'aime call of war et je sais
pas moi qui chante et si vous suivez la
chaîne depuis cette vidéo fait partie
des plus anciens de la chaîne alors je
comprends que cette news puisse être
étonnante je vais tout vous expliquer je
suis trop content d'enfin en parler
prendre la parole à ce sujet j'ai une
tonne de choses à dire mais on va
commencer par l'essentiel à savoir
pourquoi j'ai fait un album après je
veux raconter des trucs qu'ils sont
arrivés pendant la création d'albums et
qui sont terribles faut que j'aie
extériorise ça fait trop longtemps
l'année dernière après les hits de l'été
j'ai continué à faire des sauts en
studio avec plein de gens du milieu qui
sont très très fort là dedans puisque
c'est leur métier et j'ai adoré et c'est
la première fois que je faisais des sons
sans avoir en tête le fait de les mettre
en ligne
après sur ma chaîne youtube et de penser
au clip tout de suite là je les faisais
juste pour le plaisir pour kiffer créer
de la musique et apprendre des choses
avec des gens dont c'est le métier en
fait la musique c'est un milieu où même
si j'ai fait plein de musique sur
youtube je reste un méga débutants et du
coup comme chez oméga débutants moi j'ai
trop de trucs à apprendre et c'est hyper
enrichissant et épanouissant d'apprendre
des choses dans un milieu aussi cool que
la musique bref après toutes ces
sessions studio je me suis dit [ __ ] je
crois que je vais me lancer dans la
création d'un album il ya trois choses
qui m'ont poussé à prendre cette
décision
quand même
[Musique]
ça s'est fait à surveiller de bouche tu
n'entravera pas avant des annonces de
l'album alors le premier truc qui m'a
poussé à prendre cette décision c'est le
fait que la musique c'est une manière
très différente d'aborder des sujets et
des thèmes que les vidéos par exemple ya
plein de chansons d'amour qui parle
d'histoire de rupture de jalousie etc
mais parler de ça en vidéo à travers
l'un des formats que j'ai sur cette
chaîne youtube c'est bizarre ça s'y
prête pas le format qui s'y prêtent le
mieux ce serait la limite la vidéo
anecdotes mais encore c'est chelou et
l'on comment allez vous j'ai grandi dans
un climat d'hostilité de ouf avec ma
maman et j'ai vraiment mais alors
beaucoup manqué d'affection ça se
traduit du coup par la peur de l'abandon
aujourd'hui j'ai peur qu'on abandonne du
coup je suis un peu parano j'ai
l'impression de voir le mal là où il y
en a pas j'ai l'impression par exemple
de voir autour de ma copine comme des
guépards
ça marche très peu ça marcherait c'est
bizarre la deuxième chose c'est le
challenge que ça représente c'est pas du
tout simple de faire un album c'est pas
du tout simple de faire de la musique et
c'est ça qui est cool
en fait sur la chaîne youtube j'ai fait
plein de musique au fil des années mais
c'est des musiques que je faisais
vraiment en trois heures et c'était des
musiques humoristique c'était plus pour
faire rire que pour faire un truc qui
sonne bien rapproche met à vibrer sms
départ arrêté avec les extraits de clips
c'est bon quand tu te lances dans la
création d'un album
il faut que tu te dépasse il faut que tu
apprennes vite des choses et que tu sois
bon parce que sinon tu ta fiche et c'est
ça le truc excitant c'est d'arriver dans
un milieu où tu as très peu de
compétences ou thé personne et comme
tiko derrière la marge de progression
potentielle elle est énorme tu as
tellement de choses à apprendre puisque
tu parles de tellement loin et c'est
sacré challenge c'est de se dire je vais
faire un album et je veux en être fier
mais avant d'en être fier va falloir que
je bosse énormément et troisième point
qui dit album dit tournée
j'adore vous partager mes nouvelles
passions mes états d'âme des histoires
d'horreur et c'est sur la chaîne youtube
j'adore ça à mort mais ça fait neuf ans
que je suis sur internet ça fait neuf
ans que je fais ça et je vous ai
quasiment jamais vu genre y en a parmi
vous on s'est connus on avait 15 16 ans
aujourd'hui on en a 24 et on sait jamais
vu ça me troue le cul en neuf ans je
crois que les rares fois où je vous ai
vus c'était à des conventions et encore
j'en ai fait trois et à ces conventions
j'avais pas grand chose à vous proposer
au-delà du fait d'être là et de faire
acte de présence les concerts jiwa
l'occasion de vous proposer un vrai truc
un vrai spectacle de vous faire kiffer
autrement qu'avec que des trucs virtuel
de vous raconter quelque chose de vous
proposer un vrai show et qu'on kiffe
tous ensemble dans la vraie vie en fait
donc oui le fait de sortir un album fait
qu'il y aura une tournée et qui aura une
scénographie que j'ai énormément bossé
qui j'espère vous plaira mais on en
parle tout à l'heure là je vais passer à
la partie anecdote j'ai des trucs à vous
raconter les gars les gars créé un album
c'est incroyable c'est une expérience
folle mais il ya eu
quelques trucs qui m'ont trauma tout
simplement cet album c'est un an de
travail est au tout début de c1 1 il a
fallu que je trouve mon style peu
importe le milieu soit dans la musique
dans les vidéos dans dessins dans l'art
dans tous c'est vraiment dur de trouver
son identité
du coup j'ai exploré plein de styles
musicaux avant de trouver celui qui me
plaisait le plus et de me l'approprier
d'une manière ou d'une autre
et parmi ces styles musicaux se trouve
le reggaeton ce n'est pas du tout ma
culture squeeze et reggaeton ça va pas
du tout tous les fans de gym alvin daddy
yankee est tous là vous avez envie de
m'insulter c'est normal allez-y dit t'es
pas regarder ce dossier
maquette reggaeton franchement là c'est
comme si je m'étais nu devant vous ces
maquettes ce sont les premières que j'ai
fait quand j'ai décidé de faire un album
je veux partager ses maquettes avec vous
ça ne reflète pas du tout ce qui est sur
l'album a vraiment c'est l'opposé ti
cats sur l'album les choses
intéressantes vous montrez ce par quoi
je suis passé parce que avec le recul
quand je regarde je trouve ça use
c'est l'adjoint de marc savard groupe et
ça bouge et l'effet sur le dancefloor
tout
[Musique]
il est là
et c'est monsieur le directeur se
choquer avec une catastrophe il faut
intervenir non patricia blessé le
terminer il nous a promis une turie un
post instagram c'est une publicité
inespérée pour les siestes antigone club
de thionville est bon les gars y'a rien
de plus dur que d'écouter et de faire
écouter c'est encore pire des vieilles
des vieilles mac est horrible c'est aux
deux doigts d'annuler cette partie de la
vidéo mais c'est pas fini mais cela j'en
vois deux trois là qui veulent danser
collé serré en mode solo mais j'ai ce
qu'il faut que je suis vous la facette
par pitié faites le taire les derniers
clients qui restent commença dessaoulé
pouvoir laisser le juge finir sa merde
il en a plus pour longtemps
je sais pas si genre au bout ça sonne si
mal que ça si c'est sur c'est vraiment
horrible mais pour moi c'est d'une telle
souffrance d'écouter ça c'est un truc de
ouf heureusement c'est fini
[Musique]
jamais de telles entités l'enchanté
rassurez vous il n'ya rien de tout ça
sur l'album il n'y a pas une seule trace
très bientôt
bref une fois que j'ai trouvé mon style
à savoir les délires plus pop urbaine
cloud rap électro aussi évidemment il
fallait que j'apprenne à chanter parce
que c'est bien de trouver ce que tu
aimes et ce dans quoi tu es à l'aise
mais si on ne sait pas chanter c'est
chaud la voix c'est un instrument genre
il faut vraiment apprendre à s'en servir
et moi jusqu'à présent je je je je fous
j'avais appris à m'en servir de cette
manière j'ai appris une seule chose à
faire que ma voix c'est crier d'ailleurs
je crie de plus en plus dans mes vidéos
et médailles j'en suis désolé à tel
point que j'ai eu récemment une énorme
inflammation des cordes vocales et que
j'ai dû respirer dans une machine 15
minutes par jour et des
anti-inflammatoires ce dépôt sur mes
cordes vocales
rassurez vous tout va mieux et surtout
j'ai dû réapprendre à utiliser ma voix
parce qu'en fait je l'utilisé très mal
je forçais beaucoup trop dessus
bref pour apprendre à chanter j'ai donc
pris des cours de chant je sais je sais
et mon premier cours de chant fut une
affreuse expérience-là profiter super
bass pas sa faute
[Musique]
déjà le premier truc c'est que
j'appréhendais à mort je savais que
j'allais devoir utiliser ma voix et
chanter premier degré devant quelqu'un
chez moi et ça me mettait mal à l'aise
mais surtout j'avais mal noté la date
dans mon agenda d'accord mon premier
cours de chant je pensais qu'il avait
lieu cinq jours après et donc le jour j
j'étais pas au courant que j'avais un
cours de chant horrible ce matin là je
me réveille à 9 heures du matin parce
que mon téléphone sonne je pensais que
c'était un livreur qui venait me livrer
quelque chose
pas du tout une jolie voix me dit je
suis un bain annabelle ouais je ne sais
pas du tout qui et annabelle et encore
moins ce qu'elle fait en bas de chez moi
mais comme elle avait l'air sûre d'elle
annabelle je fais le mec sûr de moi
comment tu va enchanter le digicode ces
2 mai 28 voix la 5ème étage la porte de
droite je suis en caleçon dans mon lit
avec approximativement 32 épi sur ma
tête et je n'aime pas faire mauvaise
impression du coup comme je suis un
escroc je me lève et là je lance 2t je
ne sais pas qui est annabelle mais je
veux la mettre bien je veux qu'elle
madore annabelle même si elle vient pour
me tuer je veux qu elle même avant
annabelle arrive dans mon salon et tout
de suite
elle pose des questions sur ma voix ce
qui vous me l'accorderez est peu
fréquent j'ai jamais posé une question à
quelqu'un sur sa voie je comprends donc
il s'agit de la prof de chant que
j'attendais cinq jours plus tard
mais gros carmat dans ma gueule j'ai la
voix du matin je parle comme ça chez moi
j'ai un piano le cours de chant comme
ans annabelle elle s'assoit elle fait
des notes sur le canot et je doit
reproduire la note avec ma voix imaginez
faire ça quand t'es réveillé depuis deux
minutes seulement
ah ça a duré comme ça un petit moment
petit moment à l'issue duquel annabelle
me dit bon on a fini pour aujourd'hui on
va se revoir souvent toi et moi
annabelle tu regarde cette vidéo sache
que j'avais la voie du matin et que j'ai
tout donné mais ça n'a pas suffi j'ai
fait plein d'autres courent depuis tout
va mieux vous en fais pas mais ce
premier cours là m'a un peu traumatisé
c'est vrai là je vais vous parler d'un
truc techniques dont j'ignorais
l'existence avant de faire un album
ça s'appelle une session d coûte une
session d'écouté une réunion où il ya
pas mal de monde on va dire une dizaine
de personnes certains qui travaille pour
une plateforme de streaming et d'autres
qui travaillent pour ton label dans mon
cas old boys et qui doivent défendre son
projet auprès de ceux qui bossent pour
la plateforme de streaming en gros à
l'issue de cette cession des coutelas
plateforme de streaming va choisir si
elle ta compagne à fond ou pas dans la
sortie de ton projet est ce qu'elle va
faire des pubs sur les qualités pour
mettre en avant son projet et ce qu'ils
abattent mais dans des playlists
ailleurs vrai ses bases et juste sur la
qualité de ton projet de ce qui n'est
pas du tout un truc obligatoire mais
l'enjeu est énorme c'est hyper stressant
j'ai donc une session d'écouté prévue
depuis plusieurs semaines voire mois
avec une plateforme de streaming
sauf que je n'ai pas de mac et dont je
suis satisfait j'ai les fameuses
maquette les ghettos que vous avez
entendu et plein d'autres trucs mais
c'est que des trucs dont je suis pas
satisfait et dont je sais qu'ils ne
seront pas sur l'album mais bon le
rendez vous est prévu depuis un moment
tant pis c'est la vie et je vais assumer
garder la tête droite et faire genre que
tout va bien
j'arrive sur place et le rendez vous a
lieu dans une pièce très grande et il ya
beaucoup de gens il y a douze personnes
et j'ai vingt minutes de retard ce qui
veut dire que quand j'entre dans cette
pièce dans laquelle il ya douze
personnes personnes nées en train de
parler et se sont déjà tous dit tout ce
qu'ils avaient à dire juste ils
m'attendent pour casser ce malaise je
m'excuse pour mon retard je fais des
grands sourires je fais deux trois
petites blagues je suis en confiance ce
moment-là je me dis [ __ ] je vais dans
toutes les playlists lui le boss je
donne tout ce que j'ai je donne mon max
les gars je donne mon max mais en même
temps je parle beaucoup pour retarder le
moment où la cession des coûts doit
commencer au fond j'ai peur je sais ce
qui va se passer
le moment arrive et je leur dis alors
bon bar à quelle enceinte je connais que
mon téléphone pour vous faire écouter
les maquettes moi je me dis attend c'est
une session d'écouté
on est dans les bureaux d'une plateforme
de streaming ils vont me sortir un
système sont de dengue genre même au
reggaeton pour y va sonner
incroyablement bien sûr ces enceintes là
et ça va sauver le truc regarder se doit
non pas celui là hélas les personnes en
face me disent que leurs systèmes sont
n'est pas disponible et que du coup ils
ont pris une enceinte un peu moins bien
mais que ça fera la faire je me dis ah
ok vont sortir une dose au lieu de
sortir la phantom ii via lé seuil a pas
de souci il pose sur la table une google
comme à la grande boucle sommes pas
celle là
cette google homme-là oui bon ben vous
la connaissez vous l'avait offerte à vos
grands parents à noël dernier
et là je me dis [ __ ] rien ne
rattrapera la médiocrité de ses
maquettes ça va être dur je me connecte
à l'enceinte
je lance le premier saut c'est du
reggaeton on est tous assis en rond moi
je suis tellement pas en confiance que
je regarde le sol
je regarde le sol après quelques
secondes je me dis attend ça va leur
donner une bière pression sur les sons
les il faut que je montre qu'ils sont
bien et du coup je me met à bouger la
tête pour faire genre que sam ambiance
comme elle l'est sont là mais personne
ne semblait ans comme ça sauf si tu fais
un bad trip mais là il n'est pas
question de ça le reggaeton n'a l'air
d'avoir convaincu personne du coup je
lance une deuxième maquettes des fois je
lève les yeux comme ça vers les gens je
lance des regards et malheureusement je
vois que tout le monde est en train de
faire comme moi à savoir regarder le sol
ce qui veut dire que tout le monde
ressent comme moi rire du tout cette
musique ne transmet aucune démo ce
qu'une personne n'ose dire ce qu'il
pense réellement et tout le monde fait
genre bien mais là aurait bien parce
qu'ils veulent pas me vexer ils veulent
pas mettre mal
ouais je sais écouter trois quatre
autres maquettes et j'arrive à la fin de
la session d'écouté il ya une sorte de
mal de nuque général puisque tout le
monde a été comme ça pendant quinze
minutes je me lève je me dis que ce
moment est derrière moi que je peux
rentrer chez moi et pleurer un coup est
passé à autre chose
lorsqu'une main me tape l'épaule je me
retourne et je constate que face à moi
se trouve le boss de mon label et ce
boss me dit la chose suivante le cas il
ya un truc de deux filtres à régler la
sur ta voix non
vous vous rendez compte de la violence
de cette phrase c'était tellement pas
abouti ces maquettes que le boss du
label lui-même est venu gentiment bien
attentionné il pas venu méchamment mais
l'élu lui-même me dire des gros t'avoir
ya un truc à faire là bref depuis j'ai
fait des sessions d'écouté avec des
potes et même des inconnus et ce que
j'ai vécu ce jour-là c'est juste lié au
fait que c'était des maquettes donc
j'étais pas du tout fier et qui ne me
correspondait pas du tout et donc si
moi-même ce que je fais écouter j'ai un
sentiment malaise va bien évidemment que
quand quelqu'un d'autre va l'écouter il
aura le même sentiment encore les mois
passent et je bosse sur mille choses les
vidéos la marque les laver etc à me
connaissait et du coup je me dis bon il
faut que je trouve le moyen de consacrer
plus de temps que ça l'album parce qu'il
faut que je progresse jeune homme pris
une décision qui a été crucial en fait
dans la création de cet album je pense
que si j'avais pas pris cette décision
là je n'aurais jamais sorti l'album
parce que j'aurais pas atteint le niveau
que je voulais atteindre cette décision
s'était tout simplement de partir trois
semaines au japon pour faire que de la
musique
quoi de mieux que d'aller dans mon pays
préférés pour trouver l'inspiration et
la force de bosser encore et encore sur
ce projet musique
et si je vous parle du japon c'est que
j'ai une anecdote à vous raconter qui
n'a écoutez moi bien rien à voir avec
l'album et que j'ai comme envie de vous
raconter les gars et adhère vidéo de la
saison se fait kiffer
on arrive au japon le premier soir je
suis trop content parce que je sais que
je vais pouvoir bosser un plein temps
sur l'album sans penser à quoi que ce
soit d'autre
et en plus il y avait des tur avec moi y
avait mis dies un petit bail avec les
âges étaient vraiment bien entouré le
premier soir on arrive on est tout
excité pour fêter ça on se met une
énorme casque d'accord je le fais
rarement pour être honnête avec vous
mais ce soir là on se décoller on a donc
fini dans les rues de shibuya autour de
3 heures du mat et là bas on a la dalle
et quoi de mieux quand tu vis moment de
faim intense après une soirée que
d'aller taper un bon gros quais bas on
va donc au kebab avec sam tiba je bave
en sentant l'odeur est sur ma gauche
j'entends un mec parler tout seul je me
dis alors comme n'importe quel et
m'inspirer mais qui est ce mec qui parle
tout seul
à 3h du mat devant un kebab je tourne
alors lentement la tête vers la gauche
et que vois-je
une caméra pointée sur moi les gars au
japon il ya un mec qui fait des live
tout le temps dans tokyo et j'ai eu la
malchance de tomber sur ce mec à 3h du
mat le seul soir où je bois de tout le
voyage
je comprends alors la dangerosité de la
chose je suis en live sur twitter bourg
et ses badauds et je m'apprête alors à
fuir ma destinée en faisant un demi tour
parfait pour prendre la fuite lorsque
mon pote sam je ne sais pas pour quelle
raison il avait trop bu c'est clair dit
aux mecs que je suis moi aussi un
streamer eu pour conséquence de lancer
un dialogue entre moi et ce mec
diallo qui s'est retrouvé au plan live
sur twitter crise il ya 0.6 muriel loup
garou hier est occupé en angola
do you play loup garou en youtube
l'anecdote le japon ça a été genre un
élément crucial dans la création de
l'album parce que j'ai enfin trouvé mon
style j'ai enfin pu travailler ma voix
comme il fallait que je la travaille
j'ai enfin trouvé les effets que je
voulais mettre sur ma voix et surtout
j'étais enfin à l'aise à 100% avec le
fait de chanter et avec les maquettes
qu'on a créé le genre là j'étais fier
des maquettes que j'avais j'étais fier
des sons et ça change tout d'ailleurs
j'étais tellement à l'aise que je me
suis dit j'adore des meilleurs ouais je
lui proposais un feat
sauf que je suis un lâche écoutez j'ai
fait comme en cm2 quand tu es amoureux
d'une fille en cm2 tu vas pas lui dire
tu envoies à même la toile lui dire que
tu lèves toi tu n'y vas pas en aucun cas
et ben elmir j'ai fait la même
j'ai envoyé quelqu'un j ai pas peur qui
disent non j'avais peur qu'ils aient une
image négative de moi juste à cause du
fait que je vais proposer un feat et qui
se disait avec l'hôtel villa et ça
dégage bref j'ai donc envoyé quelqu'un a
demandé et franchement je me disais
jamais ça passe mais on tente mais
j'avais ça passe les jours passent je
transpire à grosses gouttes à l'idée que
des maires se moque de moi lorsque
soudainement essais squeeze qui pose
parce que j'ai du mal à le reconnaître
est en ce moment en tout cas franchement
si le projet là cette qualité ça va en
surprendre plus d'un tube
franchement là bas il n'avait pas tort
je rigole mais je suis très content des
retombées sur guépards et ça m'a fait
trop plaisir
bon au final vous connaissez la suite le
fit c'est fait je suis allé avec des
murs en studio on a fait des pas pouvoir
travailler pouvoir collaborer avec un
gars donc tu adores le travail et que tu
respecte profondément c'est un truc
tellement enrichissant c'est tellement
épanouissant c'est un sentiment genre
indescriptible et d'ailleurs cette
rencontre et se fit avec daimler m'a
donné le courage de proposer un fit un
autre artiste dont j'adore aussi le taf
et qui a accepté et que vous découvrirez
du coup en mettant que la tracklist dans
quelques semaines bref c'est tout pour
les anecdotes il y en a pas beaucoup et
tant mieux
tout s'est plutôt bien passé je suis
très content je vous parlais d'un
dernier truc c'est que faire un album
au delà de faire de la musique c'est
aussi bossé sur une scénographie pour la
tournée est aussi sur l'objet physique
l'album alors je vais pas vous parler de
la scénographie et vous la montrer parce
que ce serait con de spoil de ça mais
oui aura bel et bien une tournée dans
toute la france non pas de me top mais
de concert il y aura vingt dates les
plats sont pas encore en vente je vous
tiendrai au courant de quand elles le
seront mais je suis vraiment content
parce que je vais vous voir et je vais
vous proposer un vrai truc sur lequel
j'ai énormément travaillé pas tout seul
bien évidemment il ya toute une équipe
qui a travaillé sur la scénographie mais
je suis vraiment content du visage que
va voir le concert et j'ai hâte de vous
y voir j'ai vraiment
et enfin à l'objet physique l'album en
fait je trouve qu'aujourd'hui quand on
achète un cd fin en tout cas moi dans
mon cas je l'achète pas pour écouter les
musiques qu'il ya dessus je les écoute
déjà sur les plates formes de streaming
je l'achète juste pour avoir un bel
objet pour avoir un souvenir de cet
album que j'aime et aussi pour soutenir
l'artiste évidemment et c'est pour cette
raison que je voulais pas faire ce qu'on
appelle un cristal c'est à dire une
boîte classique avec juste une pochette
je voulais faire un truc vraiment sur
mesure j'ai bossé très durement avec
regular un artiste incroyable survenus
sur instagram
on a ensemble du coût des années l'album
physique que vous allez découvrir
maintenant
[Musique]
oh
alors je suis ému là sachez que le
design de l'album physique est
totalement liée à l'histoire qu'il ya
autour du projet vous pouvez dès
maintenant le précommander comme ça un
album spécial il en édition limitée y en
aura pas à l'infini donc voilà pour ceux
qui le veulent pas allez-y foncez
le lien est dans la description c'est
oxis point fr et vous allez le découvrir
aussi un bout de l'histoire que j'ai mis
autour de ce projet là qui j'espère vous
plaira histoire que vous pourrez aussi
découvrir sous forme de tout petits
courts métrages dans une ou deux
semaines
bref je suis trop content d'avoir enfin
pu vous parler de ce projet ça fait un
an que je bosse d'arrache-pied dessus et
pas que sur la musique aussi sur l'objet
aussi sur la scénographie est aussi sur
les clips cet album j'espère qu'il
plaira à ceux qui suivent les vidéos à
ceux qui aiment ce que je fais à ceux
qui ont envie de découvrir une autre
facette de moi j'ai mis une partie de
mon âme j'ai raconté des choses que je
n'aurais jamais osé raconter autrement
que par la musique tous ceux qui sont
réticents à l'idée que je fasse de la
musique
il n'y a aucun souci je comprends moi je
voulais juste faire un projet qui me
correspond et je voulais surtout
m'amuser et me challenge et et c'est
exactement ce que j'ai fait et je suis
très fier de ce projet j'espère vraiment
que ça vous plaira je suis très content
a reparlé ça me fait du bien ça fait des
mois et des mois et des mois que j'ai ça
en moi et que j'ai envie d'en parler et
que je peux pas parce qu'il faut
attendre le bon moment et là enfin j'ai
accouché je viens d'accoucher en pleine
vidéo [ __ ] je me sens libéré
j'espère vraiment que le projet vous
plaira j'ai hâte d'avoir vos retours
j'ai hâte aussi de vous balancer le
petit court métrage dans une semaine
j'ai hâte de vous balancer le prochain
son bref c'est le début d'une nouvelle
aventure pour moi ce projet d'album et
c'est hyper excitant et je suis super
content d'être allé au bout et d'un
autre côté je me sens vide là d'avoir
fait cette vidéo ça fait bizarre de
partager ça avec vous d'un coup bon
allez je vous dis à bientôt passer très
bonnes vacances bisous tout le monde
c'est charmant
[Musique]
jean comme tu parles quand tu passes la
nuit dans les bras
plat
[Musique]